and with me at this desk my personal
happy place and my trusty co-pilot rossi
ross matthew hi everybody
may the fourth be with you you've got
may the fourth and cinco de mayo it's
all happening it's a great month i know
well first up in the news we have got a
brand new gem from the tick tock mines
oh that well we love it so much so you
know dark circles obviously are a thing
they're one of my personal hardest
things yeah you've talked about it here
a lot well i have dark circles uh-huh
and refinery29 reports that a new makeup
hack can make them disappear all you
have to do is take your concealer
ideally a tone or two down from your
foundation
and draw a fun pair of glasses on your
face and then of course make sure you
blend don't leave it like that basically
what i think this is great for is do you
know how in the bronzing world we have
the magic three
um this is what how you're supposed to
bronze it's called the magic three it's
a backwards three on your face
rossi you're doing it of course i'm
doing it hello perfect
so if we have information about where
we're supposed to bronze maybe we need
the glasses hack for where we're
supposed to conceal everybody needs a
facial road map bronze
conceal okay well i'm do i look better
yeah
so hard
do you have a beauty blender do i do
have a blender okay so now i'm going to
blend yeah okay here you go i think i'm
starting to look pretty great oh god
no you keep blending keep blending yeah
you just keep blending okay blending
okay
i kind of this looks like i'm preparing
for my job at the circus right a little
bit
well if we are carnies i don't know who
it is
how does that look do i look
oh i just woke up
it's good it looks good yeah and you
know i would never bc ross it looks good
yeah yeah oh i hi it's me thank you for
noticing all right well the magic three
bronzer just got a sister and it's the
eye
glasses shape concealer try it home it
works i my beauty is exhibit a thank you
so much
all right next we got a big question
about etiquette after breaking up you
know it's always so confusing after a
breakup how do you handle it well the
mere reports a woman posted this on
reddit listen she says her ex-boyfriend
wants her to stop going to his favorite
restaurant back when they were dating he
introduced her to this amazing korean
barbecue spot
i'm in i love korean barbecue
food doesn't right but now they split up
and then he ran into her there when he
was out on a date with somebody else and
he accused her of stalking him and asked
her to stop eating there and she says
she doesn't care about him she's there
for the barbecue and i side with this
barbecuing let me tell you something
i do too
if there's a place that's got amazing
ribs and you don't want me to go there
anymore i'll break your ribs
you don't get the restaurant in the
divorce i'm sorry you don't you don't
get custody of the barbecue ribs i
completely agree i love i oh god i have
such a rebellious side i would have just
loved if this guy was like you're still
into me i would have just wanted to
kick his butt you know i do it's like oh
god i'm here for the meat not you
i'm just here for the meat i'm just here
for the meat this has nothing to do with
you it's been a year get over yourself
get over you so i say to this woman you
just eat dine bon appetit absolutely
preach barrymore
[Music]